a list celebrities the top top
celebrities are on your show now not
always the case when you were first
starting out you couldn't get the title
first season of the show I didn't know
famous people just a meeting in New York
I happen to know the late great Joan
Rivers she was a fan of mine she did the
show and then I knew Rachel Dratch right
I know you go wait yes and Rachel was a
fan of mine so she did the show and the
first thing we asked her to do we played
a game she had no preparation for it I
put time on the clock like 60 seconds
and I said name 20 white people go right
right and she had a complete meltdown
and couldn't do it yeah like a nervous
breakdown you could it's like watching a
person have a stroke in real time she
just started screaming out the names of
various SNL colleagues of hers than her
parents that she couldn't do it she
didn't do it because you know what the
thing is it's like when you're put under
pressure like that and you have your
mind has to react like that you
certainly like you know like you
certainly can't name your kids right
exactly we did name 20 Latinos with Tina
Fey she couldn't do it right we did name
10 gay people with keegan-michael key he
couldn't do it everyone fails I think we
should try it with you right now what do
you categorize your went to Harvard
doesn't matter yeah the dumbest people
go there that's true the dumbest people
here we go
30 seconds on the clock you guys ready
Conan O'Brien named 20 famous white
women go
oh uh Meryl Street Hillary Clinton yes
they have to be live no oh 20 years
only two minute Barbara Eden she played
Jeannie on I Dream of Jeannie yes Sally
Field Supreme Court justice what's her
name you know her name come with me
[Applause]
I think you don't get four or five ice
cream you say I think you've got four I
asked for 20
well twenty and thirty seconds is a lot
oh shut up Andy that's like I swear to
God it's really hard because it's too
wide a category white women yeah there's
a lot of them yeah yeah Wow
all right know that you'd certainly
humbled me that's what I do
yeah glad that one of them was barbara
eden why why and then could have just
named your family no they have to be oh
they have to be famous that was the
prize was the timekeeper I wasn't paying
attention to the rules
you